[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
if you find thousands
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no no
[Music]
let's pick it up
[Music]
[Music]
attached
[Music]
that don't match give up
hint one militech and two
[Music]
valentino
[Music]
[Music]
we're all gonna die
[Music]
so
[Music]
for a little while
[Music]
you have something twisted
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
it's v took care of jose nice work
[Music]
[Music]
he and his crew were hired to launch a
full-blown assault on an arasaka
facility
and to do it using militech equipment
on arizona
[Music]
maybe and
jose's hit was meant to be their excuse
kind of slim don't you think
it's not just so saying i've heard of
other cases
same ammo this runs deeply
but why war they're still picking up
pieces from the last one
no bigger smokescreen than more
maybe they need the attention of
something else
not sure i even want to know you padre
not this time now not my ball
not my game see you robbie
yeah be seeing you
you don't want to [ __ ] with me
oh whatever
[Music]
[Music]
you